[Music]
before we move off this topic can I ask
if you're currently a hologram this Su
just at least one topic has been covered
before Dr Wong bothered to confirm
whether she was talking to a human
hologram or human hologram dinosaur
hybrid and have you met Rick Sanchez
would you let him bang your therapist I
don't believe in therapy I don't believe
in the Cleveland Browns yet the
statistics show them being consistently
for the past 20 years we've got a
situation in the state of Virginia all
of the words on these screens looking
handwritten instead of typed suggests an
even bigger situation in this room Nazis
that's everywhere that's an exaggeration
sir it is not you've heard the state
model Virginia's for lovers that's
actually more of a tourism slogan we all
know that the modotto has something to
do with a T-Rex that had fallen ill
while putting on a Stage production that
was critically panned by Abraham Lincoln
America knows and incinerates a cat when
it sees one swift e have entered the the
chat assimilated the administrator and
have begun to use it as a hub of
organizing resources and planning the
Takeover and conversion of the MSG
sphere into an extra solar vehicle three
Danger episode will not pay off this
Yeti prophecy but the show will expect
me to be impressed when they bring it
back a year from now in an episode about
the Abominable Snowman accidentally
consuming whatever the space equivalent
of cocaine is I'm so sorry Mr President
Virginia is closed to visitor believing
that Virginia completely isolating
itself is a problem that requires fixing
this parenthetical seems like a wholly
inadequate way to describe the weapon of
mass destruction that is Rick
Sanchez damn it Rick and Morty is this
going to be a vomit episode the fact
that you picked vomit as your mind
control delivery method of choice
instead of touch brain waves oring hand
jobs is more about you than it does me
why would you want to animate this
instead of a hand job so that's it
you're all just drunk realizing key
elements of your fandom seven seasons in
pick up your phone [__] when I call
it's an actual emergency but if it's an
e emergency why did you reach for the
phone instead of the portal gun you were
obviously coming here anyway and who
chooses to add a phone call to their
existence if at all avoidable we're
surrounded and unity knows your reload
time not thinking that Rick would be
able to randomize his refractory period
calm down we can't because we're worried
about you vomit aside I was actually
having a great time with this episode
until it revealed that Unity traveled
across the Galaxy assimilated entire
State and declared independence from
America all to get Rick's attention so
she can talk about how much he still
cares which ironically means I suddenly
don't I tried calling but is it true
you're looking for him again when you
pronoun game this explicitly I start to
question my efficacy and no one makes me
question my own
efficacy sorry that was supposed to be
suppressive every American conflict ever
queue up the Dome yes sir equipping your
helicopter with a big ass handle for the
sole purpose of activating a dome is
completely in line with what I imagine
the government beam counter believe to
be fiscally responsible do you have a
dome the size of every
state you'll need a second date for that
answer trading State secrets for second
dates the Constitution clearly states it
has to be at least a fourth date SLC
base situation to avoid an impeachment
also I don't know what's more
objectionable that he counts hiring her
as a first date or this trip to vgia a
nation in turmoil tonight as the entire
state of Virginia continues to be
trapped inside an energy Dome a nation
in turmoil I very much doubt any one in
Georgia Nebraska or Connecticut is
giving any of their to Virginia being
turned into a snow globe sand snow this
president has been in office for how
many alien invasions listen disastrous
happens regardless of who bought their
way into office what you should
criticize him for is how terribly he
handled each disaster oh and his
dependence on an aoral chaotic neutral
cybernetically enhanced grandfather and
a 14-year-old then he sees reginia with
its perfect economy and synchronized
lawn mowing so he shoots them and puts
them in a dome is she totally ignoring
the zombie people in their oral
evictions either this is what Virginia
looks like on any given day or this news
channel is willfully ignorant of the
truth and spreading
misinformation it's both isn't it now I
get to beat you bring it what is this a
pocket Constitution when has that ever
been used to hold a president
accountable if it connects to another
mind it could become its own colony oh
wow you made a PowerPoint nice try Rick
but one slide with a fancy graphic does
not a PowerPoint presentation make I'm
going to need flashy text transition at
least three different fonts per slide
and proof that you spent 3 hours looking
for the perfect image from the depths of
clip art also how many times do I have
to explain this if adding one extra mind
to a Mindless Collective would give it
Direction social media would have solved
the problem that is Ohio years ago I'm
sorry you lost a finger but that's the
price of surprise butt
play I mean come on that's hilarious and
good advice if you invite me to the
wedding I will in the punch R's got a
dooo in his butt clush I need boundaries
oh here's a big one face kids fact is
nothing short of literally a 100%
approval rating is going to save Curtis
in the next election this deusex news
position inspires president Curtis to
finally use check off's hive
[Music]
mind but why didn't an intelligence
already Under the Dome take control of
the hive why not a squirrel a pigeon or
reasonably resourceful rat basically I
refuse to believe President Curtis is
the smartest organiz left Under the Dome
such a beautiful scene everyone kisses
kissing intimate vomit exchange whatever
you want to call it why is no one taking
a defensive posture or at least closing
their own mouths uhoh did somebody close
the lady tunnel government officials
finding a way to blame a problem on the
female reproductive system someone order
a cranky dick the slogan for my rejected
windup sex toy somehow makes it into the
script he's going to assimilate the
Earth faster than I can fight it
previous seasons have made Rick so
unbelievably powerful that now when Rick
says he can't solve something I don't
believe that either I need unity's help
so you need to convince her I'm worth it
you aren't you're a therapist saying
this to you inbound vessel detected tell
him to turn around when your crew is
part of your hive mind you generally
don't have to give audible directions
right tell me in person I'm already here
damn it but your ship was just you have
your gimmicks I have mine knowing Rick
but not knowing that one of his gimmicks
is portals you had an outer space lady
who was worried for your life and your
response was hostile enough to cause a
huge problem this feels like some utter
cter guys do therapy couldn't Unity have
just like you know left him the fck
alone I can count on one hand the number
of times I broken up with someone left
them a few voicemails and then decided
to force my will upon an entire state of
a Sovereign Nation on a planet that
isn't my own it's almost never my go-to
reaction so you're asking for an
invasion yes he was but I don't think
that meant it had to be a textbook
Rolland Emir style assault on all major
cities and recognizable landmarks with
wide establishing shots cliche kind of
invasion this just looks like a typical
day in Las Vegas
I can smell this episode I should not be
able to smell an episode fire
extinguishers evolving to be exactly the
same for far- off alien species as they
are for humans on Earth and then hitting
a technological Plateau this mini fridge
would be just as accessible with a door
on the front of the cabinet as it is
popping up through the counter I've
mistaken this over engineering is actual
space saving for years heard you were
saying some really great things about
scientology if you ever want to meet and
play back acknowledging that South Park
raised the bar so high on Scientology
Burns that you have no option but to
settle for the low hanging
fruit call it separated
idea
scarf everyone kisses hello
[Music]
sir
oh yes I hate this it is revolting it
ain't about how hard you hit it's about
how hard you can get hit and keep moving
forward Rick meet fle
flag
Onyx here is a Weapon Specialist my name
is C I'm kind of like the leader in here
I'm made of rocks and I'm using your
last paycheck to cover the stapler you
stole which was my heart Welcome to Hell
mother que up the Dome yes
[Music]
sir do you have a dome the size of every
state Ro Shambo for the Dome doc you
ghosted me which side note was a
terrible movie what are you
doing do you know what it really reminds
me of tasty weat